[Music]
and his own news to taunt this is new
rap name submitted by boneless pizza my
favorite what is all hold this pizza is
the never seen you might test I just
picture something really weird that's
why I think I'd be paralyzed on effect
with the chicken drum in it with no bone
and then the crust came out the end of
it I don't know why I just pictured a
regular pizza now I pictured a pepperoni
pizza with a bunch of bones on top but
then they took it off boneless okay this
woman is a human chimera with two skin
tones and few immune systems on oh my
marrows primaries when it's like two in
one there's like chimera DNA would they
have two separate DNA's to marry you
have two different eye colors oh they're
all like crime scenes were like what is
it it's two kinds of DNA but it's one
person yeah oh my god crazy let's see
this [ __ ] this person is like a Siamese
twin and one centaur so you know all the
butt injections women getting lately
they're so [ __ ] huge they look like
centaurs man they'd love Mount Hood I
still want to see it impersonal
receptors or like docks
yeah oh yeah like Daisy Duck let's see
the [ __ ] I'll show you after I tell you
because let me show you you not gonna
let me tell you so Taylor she's 33 years
old she's a model and singer from
California that's awesome she's been
diagnosed with genetic chimera ISM all
which is an extremely rare condition we
just did you know maybe we can have a
different DNA from you too because it
takes the other DNA or to some [ __ ] or
number like you're you're parasitic twin
become crazy yeah yeah I know that's
happened so under have only been 100
known cases around the world and so what
happened with Taylor is that she
absorbed her paternal twin all alone she
never knew old child ah so she's a twin
but a single but how does she absorb it
like literally like in the womb
well he has the strength of a full adult
a defeatist Wow
haunted by that sister or is it like
South Park where there's that thing you
know I think she absorbed her
superpowers and now she has the powers
of two into one
well you would think right so part of
her DNA lives in Taylor making her a
camera and so um she never knew like
throughout her whole life she didn't
know that she had this but she always
thought that she had like this weird
birth bridge my god or something wall
and her stomach which I will show you
the space [ __ ] stomach it's like
there's a clear line this think I have a
line that let it separate not like that
one
it's like two skin tones understand me
body is it like a dick okay the big is
like part of a different color into the
flexibility yeah
well guys it seemed right in the middle
of the bowl see it's two sewn together
why did your semen oh yeah it's like uh
stopping you know like the stocking bang
on the head I can't look at his well
gonna to change that's it like that one
well did it is so Harry you can't be
done by rating Oh hold on I cemetery I
just wanted to keep moving on oh thank
you oh wait anyway cells back in 2009
that's when she she discovered she read
about this other baby that had similar
symptoms as her and so she doesn't she
realized like oh crap I have that so she
went to the doctor and then she told the
doctor and the doctor ended up running
some tests and then they discovered that
yes she was a chimera okay here is life
it finally hit so it's a damn picture
yeah dying that's just a bad sunburn you
liar whoa she's like to face but to
stomach Oh
pretty much right for a smart Batman too
bad it's like Batman to face but it's to
stomach laid out the Sun and covered
everything but that side yeah it's to
skin tone always really self-conscious
of that her stomach she would always
cause it's not normal yeah it's not
normal she thought that she had
the really large birthmark Neapolitan
ice cream without the chocolate no she
looks like imitation crab oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's right yeah I think
she's worried about the wrong part
because she is still a beautiful lady no
no no look at her something like oh I'm
just looking to pull out but that's
crazy so ever had sex what that is
constantly having a threesome Oh
weird cuz I soon as her boyfriends like
can we have a threesome she's like
didn't we already uh BAM
yeah so it's crazy because of her body
like one side of her body will react
differently to certain type of movement
as a metal Oh people like one is
allergic to silver the other ones
allergic to gold something like that I
don't know the specifics but she's just
mentioning that and then she also
mentioned that she has two immune
systems in her body that are constantly
fighting oh [ __ ] that's not really weak
immune to food that's uh we didn't get
along that's like an internal battle two
different blood so it's her [ __ ] twin
getting vengeance good luck you could
kill me did you I don't know why they're
to another voice but evil twin I know I
wonder if a nipple look different hmm
that means one finally do the one immune
system went the twins going to come out
oh [ __ ] this is someone I free was a
little [ __ ] gremlins in the finish if
I could discard
how does she survive so long with two
different immune system is constantly
fighting each other no no I will not
wait till I free myself I see of
attacker not a second time is a full
metal obvious [ __ ] learner editors so
she's double allergic if one's allergic
to something nothing's allergic to the
end it just keeps allergic alert I
wonder what no like wait what is like
one side your tastebuds are different
this one is prefer sweets the other one
prefers older and right now we're just
hearing all the problems but what are
all the benefits I'm pretty sure there's
like extra cool [ __ ] yeah the chef
double Somerset judges SSI is going to
blow up as a mom
for verse a see instantly well because
they like exploiting people who have
different you know things out that yeah
what if what if what is like their
bodies react differently to building
like to working out like one body is
buffer sauce in the other controllers to
DNA that's really possible yeah and um
yeah so because of the fact that she has
the different DNA inside of her system
the body treats it like a foreign Micah
for no [ __ ]
and so foreign my treat of the other
opposite opposite site via the opposite
of my insults are doing it yeah yeah
wonder won't heaven if she needed a
transplant well one side a body rejected
that's a good question because she's
saying that whenever she gets tests and
like medical test done she has to
disclose anyone that is a chimera they
had to disclose the cyclope are a
chimera because and they'll get abnormal
results two different blood types
yeah nobody an excuse a little weird
yeah because you're from West rehab
that's so crazy because like so if you
draw blood from the left or the right if
it comes out different DNA that's
looking created that is now then the
whole body shares the one blood because
I knew bloodstream
whoa one on the side and so was like so
what if someone gets her pregnant like
which who's the mother her or her twins
that's not weird but they're both her
but she can also two twins DNA yeah
so to [ __ ] the baby can come out with a
completely different than her a while I
don't know why this doesn't and then
excitement for something then we don't
have a large you're a [ __ ] anime nerd
everything in full middle yeah
Tamera Nina's the dog I know yeah but
this is way different I think the whole
world is talking about oh this is so sad
this is so troubled this but I'm
thinking about what all the superpowers
she's hiding that's why I really want to
know in order to commit a crime she
believed the blood of the twin there and
they'll never find her
exactly I didn't do it who was that I
don't know he would check my DNA because
you know it was on this yeah you
committed a crime with this side but
then she's [ __ ] once they do the other
side
that's how you say no the other side
yeah delicious so I think my but they're
not going to know yeah yeah it's like
this you steal with the right but you
show the left hand mm-hmm that's how you
do it does she look not a finger
fingerprints I was thinking right now I
don't know two different I buildings
though because she just talked about her
immune system and her bloodstream
nothing about like any other organs in
your body what if her stomachs
lactose-intolerant for her body her
butthole could be like doesn't honor I
don't know don't have to be a good
question everyone's all like oh I wish I
had to be you know like they're like oh
I wish I had arms from this guy legs
from this guy whatever right but people
never think about the negative effects
that also come along with it so this is
kind of like the same curse is like oh
so if you want the chest of this guy
guess what you get his heart problems
they're here I like together at the
American Horror Story the coven
they're coming where is she like should
get pieces of all these boys I died and
then actually kind of puts back together
the good lady Sullivan comment like a
witch's cousin yeah what the hell and
then he ends up like Marcos yes also you
do that's my me that my hunger game I
come so yeah anyway so Taylor recently
nebula my coven so the reason why Taylor
recently I was like telling her stories
because she wants to inspire other
people to let them know it don't be
afraid if you're different in any way
you should be confident no matter what
except if you're a pedophile yeah don't
be confident you're a petal okay like
physically different you're also yeah
Jersey there's probably a pedophile
listening right now saying really I
should follow my dreams and you know I
should I should be accepted the way I am
I'm buying an ice cream truck tomorrow
everything must not go away jakie new
topic all the money going to the bank
okay
popsicles lose it I got some Tylenol
apotheca mmm thank you hey guys thanks
for watching our last video make sure to
follow us on instagram @ JK film to
watch more videos right up there
[Music]